[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Fresh from
Google Zeitgeist,
we have author Jamie
Metzl here to talk to us
about his latest book, which
is called "Eternal Sonata."
And so in a world
where biotechnology
has increased the length
of human lifespan,
people start dying.
Researchers start dying.
What's going on?
How can we unravel this mystery?
This work of
fiction-- or is it--
is what Jamie will be here
to talk to us about today.
So please join me in
welcoming him to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE METZL: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
I'm really delighted
to be at Google
because for people who are
thinking about and writing
about the future,
it's pretty exciting
to be at a company that's
actually building the future.
I had a tremendous time
at Google Zeitgeist.
I loved working with the
outstanding team of the people
who put together Zeitgeist.
And still, I think, not
just me, but everybody
who participated in
that event is still
connected to each other,
talking to each other, and just
full of excitement
and enthusiasm
because we live
in a world that is
in a tremendous state of flux.
And the challenge that
we have, for a company
like Google or for
anybody else, is
that our brains are designed
for linear thinking.
When our ancestors were
living on the savannas
in Africa, if your parents
were afraid of a tiger,
it was pretty good to learn
that lesson from your parents
and to think, well, I'd better
be afraid of a tiger or a lion,
too, because the world had a
huge amount of consistency.
But now we live in a world
of exponential change,
and it's really
difficult for people
to internalize what
exponential change means
and how it applies to them and
how it applies to all of us.
And because of the great
work that you at Google
and others have done,
we are now at a place
where people in many ways
can internalize Moore's law.
And I don't need to explain
to the Google audience
what Moore's law is, but the
law that computing power roughly
doubles between every
18 months and 2 years.
And that's why we have
an expectation now
that our iPhones
or other technology
will get stronger,
smaller, better, faster.
And we've just internalized that
that's the way the world works.
But especially since the end
of the Human Genome Project,
we have a new
information technology,
and that information
technology is biology.
And it's really difficult
for people who've already
internalized that information
technology systems are
manipulable and hackable,
it's very difficult for them
and for all of us
to begin to think
about what it means that the
human biological system, or all
biological systems, will be
hackable and transformable.
And it's a big, big idea because
our species has been around
for about 4 billion years.
And for about 4 billion
years, from when
we were single-cell organisms
until now, multicellular
organisms, we've evolved
by one set of rules.
And it's random mutation
and competition.
And what happens if we
enter a world, which
we are entering now,
where that's not
the primary driver of evolution?
It's guided
manipulation and guided
selection, not
natural selection,
but guided, managed selection.
And what does that mean?
One of the reasons why I write
novels, among other things,
is that we don't
know what it means.
But it's not just a
scientific question.
It's not just a policy question.
It's an existential,
human question.
Not just what are we
going to think about,
but what are we going to be
as a species in 100, 1,000,
2,000 5,000 years?
And it's very,
very likely that we
are going to be a
species significantly
different from
what we are today.
In 1865, Jules Verne wrote
a story about humans landing
on the moon, and it was science
fiction, pure science fiction,
the best kind of
science fiction.
We're just imagining some
kind of crazy future.
You don't have the tools to
make it happen, but you think,
wouldn't it be neat?
And I write science fiction.
Wouldn't it be amazing
if x could be possible?
But in 1962, when President
Kennedy gave his famous speech
at Houston that the
United States was
going to put a man on
the moon in the decade,
it wasn't science fiction.
We had all of
these technologies.
We had missiles.
We had the physics to do it.
We hadn't put all of the
pieces together exactly,
but it wasn't some crazy guess.
It was real.
And with genetic technologies
leading to the transformation
of how we make babies, the
nature of the babies we make,
how we age, how we do many,
many different things,
this isn't 1865.
It's 1962.
We have all of the tools
that we need to, over time,
fundamentally
transform our species.
We haven't put all
the pieces together.
But we don't need to invent some
new, unimaginable technology
in order to do these things,
although we will, in fact, do
that, in part because
of the great work
that you guys are
doing at Google
with artificial intelligence.
And our collective
intelligence as a species
is going to get
greater and greater
and be more and more capable of
driving technological change.
But we have all of
these tools now.
And the way I like to make
this concrete for people
is to say that if you had a
time machine, if we had a time
machine and traveled
1,000 years into the past,
and we took a baby
from 1,000 years ago
and brought that
baby back to today
and placed that
child with a family,
that child would be
a normal kid, just
like anybody else at any
school down the street here.
Take the same time machine.
Travel 1,000 years
into the future.
Take that kid, and bring
that kid back to today.
And that kid would be a
genetic superman or superwoman.
They'd live longer.
They'd be immune to
lots of diseases.
They wouldn't carry.
They wouldn't have the potential
to have a lot of diseases.
They'd be more
intelligent, and then we
could go down the list
of all of these things
that child in the future
is likely to have.
And so how are we going
to get from here to there?
And it's a cliche, but we
will get there in baby steps.
And there are three
technologies that
already exist that are going
to be driving this way forward.
And the first one is IVF,
In Vitro Fertilization,
and embryo selection.
So IVF, when it
started in the 1980s,
was a revolutionary technology.
When Louise Brown, the first
so-called test-tube baby,
was born, there were people
at that time who said,
this is an abomination.
It's a crime against nature.
But now everybody accepts,
most people accept,
that IVF is a very,
very legitimate way
and an effective way
to have children.
On top of IVF,
there is a procedure
called Preimplantation
Genetic Diagnosis, PGD,
or Preimplantation
Genetic Selection, PGS.
What that basically
means is in IVF,
a woman has her eggs extracted.
And the average number of
eggs extracted in this process
is about 15.
Sometimes it's a bit more.
Sometimes it's a bit less,
but that's the average.
And in IVF, then those eggs
are fertilized by sperm.
The average male
ejaculation, I guess
we can say this at Google, has
hundreds of millions of sperm,
whereas the egg production,
as I mentioned, is limited.
So you fertilize
however many eggs
you have of those that
can be fertilized.
And let's just say you
have 10 fertilized eggs.
In PGD or PGS,
what you do is you
let those fertilized eggs grow
to be 5-day-old zygotes, which
are early stage embryos.
And then you extract two
cells from each of those,
and then you screen those
using genome sequencing.
So just a little bit of an
aside on genome sequencing,
in 2003 when the Human
Genome Project ended,
it had taken 10 years, 13 years
actually, and cost $1 billion.
Today, we can sequence a
genome in a couple of days,
and it costs $1,000.
Within 5 years, it's
going to be around 50
and take hours, and after that
it's going to be even less
and take minutes.
And so what does it mean now
that in the process of PGD
we can screen using this
low-cost genome sequencing?
Well, today it means that we can
screen for a number of things,
the easy and obvious ones-- for
gender, for hair and eye color,
and for single-gene mutations,
so-called Mendelian diseases.
And you know what
some of those are.
It's Tay-Sachs, sickle
cell disease, Huntington's.
There's a long list of these.
And so today, people, especially
people undergoing high risk
pregnancies, either because
of the age of the parents
or because the parents
may be carriers
of some type of single-gene
mutation diseases,
we can screen those embryos
and decide which of the 10
to implant.
But as more and more
genomes are sequenced,
we're going to know
more and more about how
the genome works, not just
for single-gene mutations,
but for everything.
I think all of you have heard
about precision medicine,
or personalized medicine.
And everyone kind of
understands that it
means that your medicine,
your health care,
is going to be tailored
to who you are.
But what does that really mean?
Well, it means that
one of the foundations
of your medical record will
be your sequenced genome.
It will be sequenced when
you're a five-day-old embryo.
And as first millions, and then
hundreds of millions, and then
billions of people have
their genome sequenced,
and then we compare the
genotype, what the genes say,
and the phenotype of
their life experience--
how old were they when they got
some kind of genetic diseases?
How tall were they?
What was their IQ?
Did they win the Olympics
in the hundred meters?
Anything that would be
influenced by genetics,
we're going to know
a lot more than just
these single-gene mutations,
on-off switches, which
are relatively rare.
We're going to be
able to continue
to use what's called the
genome-wide association
study to figure out how
complex patterns of genes
influence certain
behaviors or traits.
So now in the process of IVF and
PGD, we're going to know a lot.
And so parents, having a
child, the first question
the parents are going to ask is,
is my child carrying some kind
of terrible genetic disease?
And everybody is going
to want to know that.
And that's why we're going
to see a significant increase
in people who don't
have indications
under the current structure
wanting to have kids, perfectly
young and healthy people,
wanting to have kids
through IVF and PGD
because we're going
to be able to screen out genetic
diseases that nobody will want.
My last book, "Genesis
Code," one of the reasons
why it was featured in
"Cosmopolitan Magazine"
is I was at a party in New
York, and I met the editor.
And I said, hey, you should
really do something on my book.
And she said, well,
what's it about?
And I'd seen how they do
titles in the grocery store.
I said, well, it's
about the end of sex.
She goes, the end of
sex, what does that mean?
I said, well, my contention
is that as people
become more and more comfortable
with embryo screening
and recognize what
embryo screening can
do for the long-term
health of their children,
that more and more
people are going
to choose to conceive through
IVF and embryo selection.
And less people will conceive
through traditional sex,
ultimately leading to the
end of sex for procreation,
not for all the other wonderful
reasons why people have sex,
but not for procreation.
I certainly think that
over the coming decades,
that is going to happen.
It'll start with the more
advantaged people in societies,
but it will eventually
trickle down.
And why will it trickle down?
Because societies
bear a tremendous cost
of treating and
providing lifetime
care to people who are born
with these genetic diseases.
And some of these
people live 80, 90 years
and very meaningful lives.
But if society wasn't
paying those costs,
and you add up all of the costs
of lifetime care for people
with genetic diseases,
and then said,
well, what would be the cost of
screening the entire population
to eliminate those diseases--
and it's very tricky
because people who already
live have these diseases.
It's not at all to say that
your life isn't valued.
It is.
But if we had a
choice as a society
to eliminate terrible diseases
that are killing people--
for example, some diseases
are killing people
by the time they're
10 years old.
And we could say, we can
guarantee that your kids
won't have those diseases.
Some people will say,
well, it's God's plan,
and we should just
see what happens.
But I think many
other people will say,
they're all my natural children.
If I can choose one who doesn't
have a terrible disease,
I think I would do that.
Once you've opened
that door, once people
are in the process of selecting
their early-stage embryos,
then there's more information
that's potentially available.
Right now, we're
right on the verge
of being able to predict
the height of a child
based on the genetic
screening when
they're a 5-day-old embryo.
Within a decade-- and my
friend Steve [? Schuh ?]
has done a lot of work
on this-- it's likely
that we're going to be able to
have a pretty good estimation,
again provided that the
child gets proper health care
and love and all those
things, but a pretty
good estimation of the
future IQ of a child
when that child is not a child
but a five-day-old early stage
embryo.
So embryo selection is the first
step in this transformation.
The second step will be
increasing the number of eggs
and therefore increasing
the range of choice.
As I mentioned,
the average woman,
having their eggs extracted,
has about 15 eggs.
But what if we could increase
that number to 100 or 1,000?
Again, as I mentioned before,
sperm is a dime a dozen.
And so we can do that
in animal studies
now through induced
pluripotent stem cells.
So basically what you do is
you take any kind of cell,
but blood and skin
cells are the easiest.
So you take, let's
say, a skin cell.
You turn the skin cell into
a stem cell, an induced stem
cell, and then
turn those induced
stem cells, which can
become anything-- that's
why their stem cells-- into egg
cells, and egg cells into eggs.
And now instead of 15
eggs, you have 100.
You have 1,000.
Let's call it 100.
And then you use your
hundreds of millions of sperm
that you already have.
You fertilize 100.
And then you grow
those to 5 days.
You take out 2 cells
from each of those 100.
You sequence each of them,
again, because by this time
sequencing will
cost almost nothing.
And then instead of having 10
choices, you have 100 choices.
And in 100 kids, of
your own natural kids,
what's the range of IQs?
What's the range of any kind
of thing that you might select?
And you'll have a little chart.
And you'll say, well, we know
that these 10 will definitely
have Down syndrome.
And these 5 may have
Huntington's disease.
And these 20 may have
a high likelihood
of being mathematical geniuses,
whatever those things are.
And in jurisdictions
where this is legal--
and it won't be in
every jurisdiction--
people will have the ability
to make those choices.
And as a society, I think we're
more comfortable with making
choices about health.
And making choices
about health and making
choices about other traits
will be the exact same process.
So it will be a policy issue.
It will be a personal choice
issue, not a science issue,
what information we'll
all be able to have.
And then the third phase of
this, again, already underway,
is using precision gene editing.
I think everybody here has
most likely heard of CRISPR.
And CRISPR is this
amazing, new technology
that allows scientists
to edit the genome
with a level of
inexpensive simplicity
that would have been mind
boggling just a decade ago.
It's the equivalent of
being at your computer
with a Microsoft Word program.
And you see something, a
letter you want to change.
You put the cursor there, and
you eliminate that letter.
And you can add another letter.
So that's what we
can do in the genome.
We can make a double-strand
cut in the genome,
and we can either
let it repair itself
with just a missing space.
We can add new DNA to
fill that hole that's
giving it different instruction
to create a different protein.
We can turn on a gene
or turn off a gene.
And so what will that mean?
Well, it's incredible because
it was only three years ago
that scientists
figured out how to use
CRISPR to alter the DNA of a
living cell, so three years.
That's a tool.
Two years later was the advent
of functional gene drives.
And basically what
gene drives does is it
puts this tool, this
molecular scissors,
inside of the DNA of a
sexually reproducing organism.
And what it basically
does is it can guarantee--
and I can go into this
later if anybody wants--
but it can guarantee that
a genetic trait becomes
dominant from one parent.
And so it means, let's
just say that you
have a fruit fly
with light eyes,
and you want to push light
eyes through the population.
You just attach this
molecular scissors
so that when this one fruit fly
mates with another fruit fly,
it doesn't matter what the
other fruit fly's genetics are
because the first
fruit fly is passing
this little tool, this
little machine, that's
changing the second.
And so it guarantees
that you will have
a specific genetic outcome.
Now you have two,
and all of their kids
won't just have that trait.
They will also have
the tool that is also
reproducing within the cell.
And so from one
mosquito, you can
transform an entire species.
And that's why
people are talking
about gene drives
as a potential way
to wipe out Zika or malaria.
The upside is you can
wipe out Zika or malaria.
The downside is if
you get it wrong,
you could wipe out
all of life on Earth.
That's the down.
But one thing is clear, that
precision gene editing is just
going to fundamentally
transform our world
at all levels-- on the plant
level, on the animal level,
and on the us level.
And when people talk
about different inventions
in human history, you think,
what were the really, really
big ones?
Well, there was fire.
There was harnessing steam
power, maybe the internet.
I mean, what are these things?
It's not like
inventing the glasses
with the little hook
that goes on your nose
so it doesn't slip.
That's a reference to a movie.
I don't know if anyone saw it.
No.
All right, but CRISPR, in
the history of our species,
it is a steam-power
level innovation.
And just this week, in Berkeley,
actually, not far from here,
there was a new approach, which
it seems very, very likely
will cure sickle cell
disease using CRISPR.
And the power of gene
editing is incredible.
And a word of warning,
though, about it
is that I, for one, believe
that humans are massively,
but not infinitely, complex.
We are single-cell organisms
that have gone wild.
And we know that we can
understand pretty well
how a single-cell
organism functions.
So if we can understand
a single-cell organism
conceptually, we should
ultimately over time
be able to understand ourselves.
Right now, our
level of complexity
is far greater than
our computing power
and the power of our machines.
But we are kind of at
maybe a linear evolution,
but our machines are at
an exponential evolution.
So there will come a time--
and it will be definitely
less than 100 years from now,
probably less than 50 years
from now-- where
our computers will
be able to understand the
complexity of the human body,
including of the
human brain, which
is by far the most complex
thing in the known universe now.
So there's a lot
that we don't know,
and we need to be very,
very careful, obviously,
in messing with complex systems
that we don't fully understand.
And that's why I think
that embryo selection will
be the entry level, the
starter drug, because you don't
need to understand
how the genome works
to do embryo selection.
You just have a guess.
And because all of the kids are
your own natural, unadulterated
children, people making
those kinds of guesses
can lead to some pretty
significant changes
across the population.
This is a lot of background.
My new novel,
"Eternal Sonata," is
about extreme life extension,
and it's the same curve.
We're going to be
able increasingly
to understand the genetic
foundation of extreme ages,
people who live longer.
And we're going to be able
to select against that.
We already, as a result of our
understanding of the genome,
have new classes of
drugs that can regulate
the balance between cellular
growth and cellular repair
because if you're emphasizing
repair, you can live longer.
We have new,
nascent technologies
for blood transfusions
that share plasma
and between younger
and older mice
and younger and older rats.
And the older rats, getting the
younger blood, become younger.
Their skin is more supple.
They remember things better.
And the younger mice
getting the older blood
transfused, they become slower.
And so we're unlocking all
of these new ways of hacking
into the human system.
It is going to make all
of these things that
seemed fixed, especially
our own biology,
increasingly seem
variable in the future.
And the adoption rates of
these technologies, they're
going to normalize.
Again, societies
will have an interest
in having healthier populations.
When people feel
it's safe, people
will want to have healthier,
maybe even more capable
children than they
otherwise would have had.
If given the
choice, people would
like to live longer,
healthier, more robust lives.
And there will be competition
on many of these things,
both within and
between societies.
That you're in a society,
and somebody else
is doing something
that potentially
will give their
kids an advantage,
will you not consider at least
doing that for your kids?
I spend a lot of time in
Korea, and in Korea people
are spending 50% of
their disposable outcome
on tutors and private education.
They have their kids staying up
till 2 o'clock in the morning
every single night, year
after year after year,
to get just a small advantage
over everybody else.
There is this arms race.
If people could make
decisions before birth
to give their kids
advantage, would they do it?
Maybe some would,
and some wouldn't.
Maybe they would do it
in some jurisdictions
and not in others.
But the history of our species
is a history of hubris.
And whatever it is,
name one technology
that had the potential
to do a lot of good,
and there were big dangers
associated with it,
that we haven't adopted.
We have, and that's our history.
But there are huge and very,
very challenging issues.
And if we just say, well,
this is just technology,
and technology will
find a way, we'll
have a disaster on our hands
because as I think all of you
are thinking, and all of
you watching on the screen
are thinking, there are massive
issues of equity, of diversity.
Our survival as a species has
been based on our diversity.
And at any one time,
there are people
who seemed like they
weren't really contributing
much who, when
the world changed,
those were the people who led
to our salvation as groups
or as a species.
And that's true
with any organism.
And so if we were to
make selections and limit
the diversity of our species, we
would do that at our own peril.
And there are huge
values issues.
Many of us come from
ancient traditions
that have very meaningful
and valuable codes of justice
and honor and good behavior.
We can't just throw those away.
Those are hard-won gains that
our ancestors have fought for
to try to figure out how to
live in communities where people
respect one another.
And just because
there's new technology
doesn't mean that
we shouldn't think
of what's the best of
our tradition, what's
the best of our
values, and deploy
them to help us navigate
this new and very complicated
terrain.
So that finally brings me
to the issue of the novel
and why I write novels.
As I said at the outset,
these are very, very complex.
They're very, very
difficult issues.
And they're human issues.
And we, as a species, don't
just respond to science.
We don't just respond
to policy memos.
Our history as a species is
that we respond to stories.
It's how we've lived.
We tell stories
around the campfire.
It's how we struggle with
things, and we have parables.
And for me, I
certainly have been
working on these issues
for many, many years.
And I've written a lot
of articles who people
like the people I know read.
But this is such a
fundamental issue
that it's a species-wide
issue, and everybody
needs to be part
of the conversation
about our future evolution
and the implications,
the big-picture implications
of today's technologies.
And that's why I've
written the book.
And then I'll just tell a
little bit about the book
and then just read you
a very, very short bit
and then would love
to get your thoughts
and answer any questions.
So the premise
behind the book is
that octogenarian,
brilliant scientists, dying
of terminal cancer,
are disappearing
from hospices around the world.
And nobody notices,
and nobody really
cares because these people
are very old and near death.
But one reporter from
"The Kansas City Star"
begins investigating
one disappearance
and starts piecing
together that there
are these other disappearances
around the world.
And that investigation leads him
to a very reclusive scientist
whose wife had died of
cancer 10 years before.
He's committed himself to trying
to find a cure for cancer.
And he finds a way
to reverse age,
to revert cancer cells to
their pre-cancerous state.
And he's all excited about it,
and it works in animal models.
But when he tries it in
humans, the complexity
of the body's response rejects
this cellular transformation.
So he experiments
and experiments,
and he stumbles upon a way
of reverting all of the cells
in the body to create
an environment where
the cancer can be reverted.
And, of course, what this means
is that he's conquered aging.
And he realizes what he's
done and how dangerous
the concept of immortality
has been for people
for so many millennia,
and he realizes
that he needs to
protect this knowledge.
And so he compartmentalizes his
research to try to make sure
it doesn't get into the wrong
hands, and then he's murdered.
Not to spoil, but that
happens early in the novel.
And then he's murdered, which
launches a global struggle
to find and control
the technology enabling
extreme human life
extension and immortality.
So it's a thriller
because I just
feel like what I
want people to do,
I want people to
be able to explore
these issues in a way that's fun
and interesting and hopefully
exciting.
And it's a love story.
There's sex, but I can't say
I did a very good job at it.
But you guys be the judge.
And maybe I'll just read
you just a little bit,
just to get a sense of things.
So this is chapter 26.
"Compared to the vast expanse
of the 4.5 billion years
of this planet, or the
nearly 4 billion years
it took life to morph from
a single-cell organism
into the hundred trillion or so
cells I lug around today, each
of our presences is but a blip.
Blip actually is
too strong a word.
We're a pimple on
the nose of a speck,
joyriding on the blip's ass.
In other words, we are small.
But each of us is the hero of
our own little play, endowed
with enough
narcissism to believe
our lives, our
presence here on Earth
during the estimated 5 billion
more years our blue marble has
left to twirl, somehow counts.
Faced with death two
years ago in a musty hotel
room in Norman,
Oklahoma, I realized
that as small as
our lives may be
in the grand scheme of things,
loving another person is
our tiny ripple in the universe,
our song into the vastness
of space, announcing the
inexplicable artistry
of our one true creation
greater than ourselves.
But over the past
two years, I've
gradually lost hold
of this insight.
Perpetually overthinking
life, I seem
to have reverted to my ongoing
dialectical battle between--
and I'll be the
first to roll my eyes
whenever Jean-Paul
Sartre is referenced--
being and nothingness.
In the last three
days, I've learned
of two men's disappearances
into thin air, come
across the body of a genius
I just met being grotesquely
devoured by jellyfish--"
spoiler alert--
"and essentially witnessed
the deaths of two police
officers caught in
a massive explosion.
No wonder my grip on reality,
whatever that strange concept
actually means, is
feeling tenuous as I
pull into Tony's driveway."
Tony is his girlfriend.
"She's running back and
forth in the kitchen,
waving her arms, as I enter
the door from the garage.
An easy smile blankets her face.
Come on, Sebastian.
Come on, she says, in
her silly baby voice.
The dog leaps in
circles with delight.
Look who it is, she says to
the dog in the same voice.
It's Daddy.
I turn, as if to see if
someone is standing behind me.
Tony seems to forgive
my poor attempt at humor
and crawls toward me.
She swats my left
shoe back and forth,
which the dog
recognizes as placing
my foot on the edible list.
Sebastian darts
in with what looks
like an irrepressible
smile, and I'm
reminded, as if
I need reminding,
which I probably sometimes
do, just how special Tony is."
Anyway, so it's written.
My hope is-- I was in
Washington for a lot of years
on the National
Security Council.
And a lot of my
friends wrote novels
that were like policy memos
with a murderer and a sex scene.
And so I'm hoping that this
is a bit better than that.
But really, it's such
a tremendous honor
for me to meet with
any number, even one,
of people who are reading my
book because, as an author,
it's such a personal experience.
You have all of your kind
of thoughts and your life
and eventually kind
of think up a story.
Then you kind of
gather your soul.
And you kind of condense
it and condense it.
And then all of a sudden, it
becomes this physical object,
and then it has a
life in the world that
is separate from you.
And people consume
it as a product.
And your little piece
of your soul hopefully,
ideally, enters them.
And so what I hope is that
if you'll read the book,
I hope you will enjoy the book.
And if it just inspires you to
think a little bit differently,
or a little bit more,
about any of these issues,
or any other issues, then
for me that's success.
So it's a real pleasure and
honor for me to be here,
and I'm happy to answer
any of your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
a bit about yourself,
your experience?
It seems that you have
traveled to many countries.
JAMIE METZL: Yes [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk about that?
JAMIE METZL: Yeah, sure, so
just a little bit about me,
this is the condensed
version of my life.
But I'm originally
from Kansas City.
But in my freshman
year at Brown--
this is connected to traveling
to a lot of countries--
I met a classmate
of mine who was
a survivor of the
Cambodian genocide.
And I was so blown away
by his life experience
that that summer I quit
my job on the first day.
I had a garage sale of all
the junk in my parents' house
and bought a ticket and went
to the Thai-Cambodian border
and got very, very involved
working in a refugee camp
and then came back and was
very deeply involved in Asia
and international relations.
And after my PhD in law school,
then I was in US government,
on the National Security
Council, and the State
Department, and Senate
Foreign Relations Committee.
And my idea was that those kinds
of problems, and the problems
that we see now in
Syria and other places,
that the refugee is
the end of the tale.
The beginning of the tail,
or the head of the animal,
is bad decisions by leaders.
And so certainly I have a
long history in government.
It's a big-- I don't
know if commitment
is the right word--
but just a belief
that we all have an
important role to play,
both in helping our leaders
make good decisions, but also--
and this comes back
to my novel writing--
in educating ourselves and
educating each other on what
the big issues are so that
we can be informed and make
smart decisions.
And we can inspire our
leaders, knock wood,
to make smart decisions as well.
AUDIENCE: So how much embryo
selection, or even gene
editing before the
embryo selection,
would it take to be evolution?
You used that term.
JAMIE METZL: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I don't know the answer to that.
It's a great question.
And I think that we'll
know it when we just
start seeing the differences.
I think that we're
always evolving.
We're a constantly
evolving species.
But we're going to
see people jumping out
of the range of what
we now consider normal.
And whether it's living
longer right-- this is a quiz.
How old was the oldest
person who has ever lived?
Yes, 122, and she was a smoker.
She smoked her whole life.
And to live such a long
time, actually lifestyle
isn't that important.
I mean, to live to 95,
lifestyle is really important.
But to get to 110, you just
have to thank your parents.
But we're going to
see people jumping out
of the range of normal.
And I think that is going to
be one easy indication, when
we have more and more people
who have beyond genius IQs
who are living longer, when
we're eliminating diseases.
And, again, not
every change is good.
I talked about this cure
for sickle cell disease,
this prospective cure
for sickle cell disease.
The reason sickle cell
disease has survived
is that it's a
bad thing to have,
but it also gives many
people immunity to malaria.
And so there are a lot of
genes that do multiple things.
It's not that every
gene does one thing.
And there's a lot of complexity.
So I don't have a
clear way of answering,
but we're going to
have a lot of people
in the not-distant
future jumping out
of the range of normal.
And that's going to be
relatively easy to identify.
AUDIENCE: To what extent
have you thought about?
And to what extent do
you go into, in the book,
some of the economic
implications?
I see both short term, where
better differentiable embryos
eventually become better
differentiable economic assets,
and long term, where things
like a 200-year-old person,
compounded interest
in their accounts
economically differentiates
them substantially more
than someone maybe
entering the workforce.
So how much have you
thought about that?
What are your thoughts?
How much do you [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMIE METZL: Yeah, I've
thought a lot about it.
The prequel to "Eternal
Sonata" is "Genesis Code,"
where I focus more on
your first question.
So there will be
huge implications,
both for competition
between societies.
There will be big
economic implications.
So on the economic sense, we're
going to eliminate diseases,
and that's going to help.
But we're going to be
a lot more competitive
between the enhancements
of the human brain, which
I think are coming, and
either the work that you all
are doing, the
brain-computer interface.
We're going to be inventing
things that we can't even
imagine, and our inventions are
going to be inventing things.
So I've definitely
thought a lot about that.
In terms of the implications
of people living longer,
we have all of
these systems that
are based on one expectation
of how long people live.
And already social
security is a good example.
We're seeing the strains when
our early assumptions are
no longer correct,
and we're going
to have more and more of that.
And that's actually a
good thing to do now.
If you have a lot
of faith, as I do,
that we are going to be living
much longer than was the model,
there are, like, some
pretty smart investments.
Definitely, everybody should
be putting into your retirement
account now.
But all of these things that
are axiomatic-- and that's
what I started with.
It's kind of axiomatic
to us that the human body
isn't that hackable.
But it turns out it is hackable.
And it's axiomatic that you live
within a certain range of life,
but it was also, in earlier
stages of not just evolution,
of human existence, not too
long ago the expectation was
much shorter than it is now.
So we were going
to grow and expand.
If you want to make
a smart investment,
just assume, which I think
is a fair investment,
that everyone in
this room is going
to live longer than the
actuarial tables would suggest.
And then if you're
thinking that,
what is the investment
that you can make?
And, of course, the answer
is buy more Google stock.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about policy and morality,
since obviously you
worked in DC for a while.
Where does policy
come into this,
because I know a lot of times
with technology, policy kind of
comes after the fact?
Uber is an example.
And when you're talking about
picking genes and picking
genders, like, we need to have
an equal balance of genders.
Obviously in many countries,
they would favor male embryos.
JAMIE METZL: That's, like,
the dumbest thing ever.
My thinking is if you want to
have national competitiveness,
pick women.
You're much better off.
But, yeah, it's
a great question.
And this is the problem
with a lot of technology.
The technology is
advancing exponentially.
But our mindset, as
I mentioned before,
is only increasing linearly.
And the regulatory
environment is only
inching forward glacially.
And that's why there's
such a dangerous mismatch.
And we've seen what happens
when there's a mismatch.
The GMO debate is
a case in point.
30 years of research has
proven inconclusively
that there is nothing more
dangerous about GMO crops
than regular crops.
And yet, because the information
battle has been lost,
people just have a feeling
that GM crops are unnatural.
And there may be other
legit criticisms,
like monoculture and
corporate control.
But in terms of safety,
really, GM crops, there's
nothing at least that's
been proven thus far that's
wrong with them.
But once it gets stuck
in people's minds
that there's something bad, it's
very, very hard to move them.
And that's the moment
that we're in right now
with all of these technologies.
And that's why I'm
pushing for and trying
to create a species-wide
dialogue on the future
of human genetic
engineering, because now
people's minds haven't formed.
And there is an
opportunity to bring people
into an inclusive conversation,
an inclusive global dialogue
that includes people
of faith and people
from the civil
society groups, people
from the corporate world,
from anywhere and everywhere.
But relatively soon, those
things are going to form.
And there's a danger
of under-regulation
because what we're
talking about is life.
And life, there must
be limits on how
people can manipulate life.
It's just unacceptable.
And there are some
people who are
in the transhumanist
community-- and there they
live around here-- who say
there should just be no limits.
Let science do what it will.
But I don't think that's a
morally defensible position.
Having said that,
there needs to be
a high level of
permissiveness because,
one, if the technology can help
cure disease and enhance life,
it will find a way, whether in
one jurisdiction or another.
And then we need to create
an environment where
this technology can-- thanks,
guys-- where the technology can
realize its potential.
But there's a big mismatch.
And that's why we need
to educate ourselves,
and we need to
educate our leaders.
And we need to make
sure that we're neither
under-regulated,
nor over-regulated.
And that's a very tall order.
AUDIENCE: You talk about, like,
how good it is to live longer,
right?
But there should be then, like,
a bad side of that, right?
Like if you live longer
than it's supposed to be,
then 100 years, maybe
you will live 150 years.
What will happen
with the work, right?
There will be so
many people already
there, all their resources.
And some of them
maybe don't desire
to live that much longer.
So what about that.
Your genes are modified
to live longer.
What if that person doesn't
want to live longer?
JAMIE METZL: So, yeah, there
are two great questions.
I'll start with the second one.
If you are an
existentialist-- and I
mention Sartre--
then living every day
is an affirmative choice.
And so if people don't
want to live longer,
I don't encourage this.
And life is wonderful.
Everyone should
live to be 1,000,
but people can make whatever
personal choice maybe.
But don't do it.
Life is great.
If you're thinking about
that, change your perspective.
But on the thing of
overpopulation, that's an issue
I get asked every time.
And I'm not at all
concerned about it,
just because when you look
at population trends now,
we're moving towards 9
billion people in about 2050.
But then, forgetting
all of this,
then the global
population is going
to start going down
pretty significantly.
And the biggest reason
for that is education.
Right now, we have big
pockets of the world
of people who are not as
well educated as elsewhere.
But that will change.
That's going to change
over coming decades.
Every society that
becomes highly educated
stops having kids.
And so their replacement rates
most everywhere-- in Korea,
in Japan, in Singapore,
in most of Europe--
it's below two
children per mother.
And the people, at
least in the beginning,
who are going to be having
access to these technologies
will be people in that
same class of people
who have access to modernity.
So I'm not concerned.
And I also feel that
we, as a species,
have the resources now easily
to feed everybody on Earth,
to clothe everybody on Earth,
to house everybody on Earth.
We've made a moral decision
that we don't want to do it.
We've made a moral
decision that we
are comfortable with
concentrating resources
in some places and letting
people starve to death
or live in extremely unsanitary
conditions elsewhere.
But today, what's
the difference?
We've seen the life experience
of everybody in this room,
and the average person in
the Central African Republic
in the middle of a
horrendous civil war,
or the people in Haiti
whose lives have been
wrecked 10 times over
over the last decade.
And so I definitely
think that there
is a moral imperative for us
to think about equity issues
today.
But I don't think
that as long as we
have good values
that that's going
to put a significant
strain on the planet.
But I could be proven wrong.
I mean, if everybody has it,
and people have more kids,
I mean, things
change all the time.
AUDIENCE: Could you
speak as an author
about the process of going
from a very society-level,
local-level vision of the
future to a more isolated story
with a specific plot?
JAMIE METZL: So it's
a great question.
And it's personal, so I don't
know how other people do it.
But for me, there
will be a big idea,
and I'll be thinking about it.
I'll often write articles
about a big idea.
And then I'll start thinking,
well, what would it mean?
Like for my last
book, "Genesis Code,"
I testified before Congress
on the national security
implications of the
genetics revolution.
And then I started writing
a book that I didn't finish,
but it was a nonfiction
book on exactly that topic.
And I was writing the preface.
And in the preface, I talked
about a national security
staffer.
I imagined a national
security staffer briefing
the president,
saying, Mr. President,
we've learned that China has
a secret genetic enhancement
program where they are
breeding super babies
and placing them
in the equivalent
of their Olympic sport schools,
but for science and math
and engineering and business.
And the president says,
what does it mean?
And the staffer
says, well, it means
that in 30 years, if they
do it and we don't, we won't
be able to compete with them.
And so what our options?
Well, we've decided there's
nothing we can do to stop them.
But we can't do it
ourselves because we
have all of these legal and
political and cultural issues.
And what can we do?
Well, we have this
idea that if we
purchase a small chain
of fertility clinics
and begin seeding the population
with genetically enhanced
babies, nobody's going to know.
And parents are going
to be so excited
that their kid is a genius
or a sports star or whatever.
So that was what I started with.
And then I threw away the book.
And I thought, well, this
is what I want to write.
And then eventually,
well, how would it happen?
If a genetically modified
person showed up,
how would we experience that?
And it's like little bits.
It's like building with LEGOs.
And then you kind of take these
little pieces from your life.
And it was same with
"Eternal Sonata."
I was thinking a lot
about life extension.
Well, what is it going to mean?
Because all of
these technologies,
they build and they
build and they build.
And then for people, like, one
day, you have an interaction.
Like, one day, I
guarantee you your company
is going to create
human experience
artificial intelligence.
Everyone in this room,
in your lifetime,
you're going to have one day
where whatever the vehicle is,
whether it's a robot or
your car or something,
you're going to be
having a conversation
with artificial intelligence
in your lifetime.
And you're going to
think, like, oh, my God.
I forgot it was
artificial intelligence.
I've been talking about
philosophy on the 101 for 20
minutes, and I forgot it
was artificial intelligence.
You're all going to
have that experience.
And think, well, when you
have that experience, what's
it going to mean to
you as a human being?
How are you going to think
about your future differently?
So for me, I think a lot
about these questions.
And then I think, you know, how
can you turn it into stories
and turn it into characters and
have the characters, as I read
you that piece,
not have characters
being kind of wooden
representations,
but real characters with lives.
And that's one of
the things that I
like about fiction is you
kind of create the characters,
and then the characters
develop a life of their own.
And they do things
that surprise you.
And I guess it's you doing
things that surprise you
because they pick up life.
And it's like a magnet,
picking up little shavings.
AUDIENCE: What other
works would you
say influenced
your current work?
JAMIE METZL: Oh, that's great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What
inspired you, yeah?
JAMIE METZL: Yeah, yeah,
yeah, you know, it's funny.
As a science fiction
writer-- I mean,
it's near-term science
fiction-- I don't primarily
read science fiction.
I like it when I read it,
but I love literature.
And I certainly have a
lot of writers who I like.
One writer who I
really love, who
I reference a lot in the
book, is Jorge Luis Borges.
I highly recommend it.
It's a short book, although
you could read it 1,000 times
and learn something new every
time, called "Ficciones,"
F-I-C-C-I-O-N-E-S. So
Borges is a big inspiration.
Yasunari Kawabata, who is a
Japanese Nobel Laureate, what
I really love about him--
it's like I'm 1,000 years away
from him-- but just, like,
the purity of the words,
the purity of the language.
So I have a lot of different
writers who I really like,
but what I try to do is draw
from a lot of different places
and then try to infuse it
with some of my own voice.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If any of your
works were to be optioned
and to be something
animated or live action,
who would you want
to team up with?
JAMIE METZL: Well,
that's a great question.
So I'm going to answer
that and another question
because, like, it's a
little bit of a fantasy.
With all my novels,
people say, well, this
should definitely--
because when you write
a book, everybody you know
says, this should definitely
be a movie.
And you should be on Oprah.
And there's 200,000 books that
come out every year in English,
and every person's
friends tell them that.
And then they say, like,
why weren't you on Oprah?
Like, what's wrong with you?
So anyway, having
said all of that,
I definitely would love for
this to be made a movie.
And I've cast all the
roles, and Adrien Brody
plays the main character.
And so for who to make it?
I wouldn't imagine
it as an animation,
just because the whole reason
I write near-term fiction is I
want this to feel to people
like it's the world today.
I don't want people to
feel it's space opera.
I don't need any Wookies.
I want people to think,
like, this is me.
This is my life.
And I'm going to LA in two days.
And anyone who will take
me, I'd be happy to have.
So, anyway, thank you so much.
It's really been a
pleasure speaking with you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]